[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen zur sail
israel ihr habt euch gewünscht dass ich
mal organisations videos mache und in
meinen stories habe ich schon erzählen
ich zeige euch mal wie man den
kühlschrank richtig einräumt und zwar
könnt ihr dabei nicht nur platzsparend
und zeit sparen sondern eben auch
lebensmittel länger haltbar machen und
energie sparen damit auch jetzt sparen
momentan geht es mir richtig coole
mitmachaktion vom bundesministerium für
wirtschaft und energie und zwar dürfte
da eure besten energiespartipps kosten
ich will jetzt einfach mal sagen die
kühlschranks hat die lassen wir jetzt
hier raus aber wie kann man im haushalt
energie sparen es hat einfach eure idee
als kurzes video oder als bild mit
diesem herrscht reck und verlinkt mich
auf jeden fall drauf und dann gibt's was
richtig größte gewinn
teilnahmebedingungen sind hier und da
können der nachschau und ich zeige euch
jetzt aber erst einmal wie ich den
kühlschrank einräume ich habe jetzt
gerade sauber gemacht und damit ich den
kühlschrank sauber machen kann muss ich
natürlich zuerst einmal den kühlschrank
aus machen verspricht nämlich schon mal
richtig gut energie und dann ist es
wirklich wichtig den kühlschrank richtig
einzuordnen
dh ihr vor der kühlschrank ist umso
besser denn umso weniger luft habe ich
im kühlschrank
ihr kennt das problem er macht einen
kühlschrank zu dann habt ihr hunger habt
gelöste geht an den kühlschrank steht
erstmal ewig dran und überlegt euch was
ihr essen möchte
und das ist eigentlich einer der größten
fehler denn dann bleibt die
kühlschranktür zu lange offen die warme
luft strömt hinein die kalte luft strömt
heraus und dann braucht der kühlschrank
wird nicht ganz viel zeit wieder um
alles wieder abzukühlen
deswegen je mehr drin steht umso besser
denn die kalten lebensmittels die
halbritter die kälte genug dazu jetzt
würde ich sagen räume hinein denn da ist
wirklich ganz wichtig da gibt es einfach
verschiedene klimazonen im kühlschrank
und die bewegen sich so etwa zwischen 0
und 14 grad
je nach kühlschrank typ und jedes
lebensmittel hat zu den perfekten
stellplatz und wenn ihr das beachtet
bleiben die lebensmittel wirklich auch
länger frisch länger haltbar und ihr
spart wirklich noch viel energie
und nur gelegentlich gibt also hier
unten habe ich jetzt das unterste fragt
das ist das fach für obst und gemüse
da müsst ihr darauf achten manche
gemüsesorten eignen sich einfach nicht
für den kühlschrank dem müssen draußen
bleiben damit sie eben nicht kaputt
gehen
da gehören zum beispiel avocados dazu
die reifen lieber bei zimmertemperatur
bananen mögen den kühlschrank natürlich
auch nicht die bekommen da braune
flecken
brot sollte man auch nicht im
kühlschrank lagern sondern lieber in
einem brutkasten so bleibt länger frisch
und trocknet vor allem nicht aus komisch
und nuss nougat creme gehört auch nicht
denken schrank kartoffeln knoblauch und
zwiebeln lagert hier am besten auch
nicht im kühlschrank sondern eher in
einem kühl vorratsraum tomaten verliert
im kühlschrank ihr tolles aroma und
zitronen und südfrüchte kommen auch
nicht in den kühlschrank weil sie die
kälte einfach nicht vertragen
ich höre jetzt hier mal mein obst und
gemüse ein was in den kühlschrank darf
und was ich auch gerade da habe da müsst
ihr auch beachten welches obst und
gemüse und nebeneinander gelagert werden
ich stelle es jetzt hier unten alles
rein
solange ich den kühlschrank hier
einräume bleibt übrigens der kühlschrank
aus hier unten habe ich ja noch das
gefrierfach
das hält aber die kälte solange der
kühlschrank aus ist gerade bei neueren
modellen ist es so dass wirklich auch
mal bei stromausfall zum beispiel ich
meine gut wir hatten
ich glaube zwei mal in meinem leben
hatte ich stromausfall aber wenn es mal
passiert dann ist es bei neueren
modellen wirklich so dass er die kälte
hält und nicht sofort alles eben
schlecht wird und wann wird deswegen
passiert da jetzt nichts und vor allem
aber das jetzt etwa 20 minuten also
länger brauche ich es nicht zum
kühlschrank putzen und einrollen
die meisten kühlschränke haben dieses
obst und gemüse farbe und da herrscht
einfach ein ganz besonderes klima
da ist die feuchtigkeit und die
temperatur so geregelt dass das gemüse
wirklich schön lange frisch bleibt
manche haben sogar 1 0 grad fach was
auch für gewisse obst und gemüsesorten
wirklich gut ist und bei manchen kann
man sogar noch die feuchtigkeit
einstellen also ganz schließen oder halb
offen lassen
darüber kommt jetzt direkt das kälteste
fach das heißt unten ist der kühlschrank
am kältesten und dann geht es nach oben
hin wärmer zu so wie eben auch im raum
die warme luft steigt nach oben
daherkommen oben die lebensmittel rein
die eben nicht so viel kälte brauchen
und unten die die am meisten kälte
brauchen wir sind bei uns jetzt vor
allem wurst fleisch und fisch
[Musik]
das fleisch ist jetzt verstaut das fach
darüber hat die perfekte temperatur für
milch und milchprodukte die räume ich
jetzt hier ein
und dazu gehören vor allem auch offene
milchprodukte weil sie eben auch dann
schneller verderblich werden sobald sie
geöffnet sind
[Musik]
und hier kommen jetzt die übrig
gebliebenen zubereiteten speisen rein
ich brauche nämlich nicht so viel kälte
wie zum beispiel fleisch fisch oder
milchprodukten
das glaubt mir doch kein mensch dass
tatsächlich mississippi üblich ist aber
ja es noch möglich deswegen kommt denkt
man der beste schokokuchen kommt aber
nicht oft vor dass er übrig bleibt aber
jetzt habe ich noch ein bisschen für
altmetall eier gehören auch zur milch
und milchprodukten hier mit rein und ich
habe mich noch mal laden lemon gehört
zum beispiel olivenöl olivenpaste die
kommen ganz oben rein und die habe ich
immer aufnimmt drehteller denn das ist
auch wirklich ein ganz ganz großer
energie spar tipp normalerweise ist das
so man geht an den kühlschrank muss erst
mal oben herum suchen und ich habe ich
einfach einen drehteller weiß genau wo
was eingeräumt ist und habe wirklich nur
einen handgriff und habe die marmelade
sofort griffbereit und vor allem könnt
ihr den ganzen teller einfach beim
frühstück auf den tisch stellen schnell
wieder einräumen und die kühlschranktür
bleibt somit nicht so lange offen
eine eingelegte paprika kommt auch da
obendrein das habe ich hier erst mal
alles ausgefüllt und jetzt habe ich hier
noch die kühlschranktür dies generell
auch etwas wärmer das heißt gerade
butter kommt hier oben rein damit die
eben nicht steinhart ist und man sie gut
aufs butterbrot bekommt und in den
meisten fällen habt ihr im kühlschrank
dann noch fächer wie zum beispiel soßen
gelagert werden können oder eben auch
ein gemachtes gemüse senf tomatenmark
wobei es hier wirklich geplatzt und vor
allem hat man es wirklich immer
griffbereit und muss wirklich den
kühlschrank nicht lange offen lassen
[Musik]
die olive jetzt fast vergessen sie
kommen ja noch mit rein zu den
angebrochenen dingen und dann nur noch
die getränke und die kommen hier in die
kühlschranktür
so ist jetzt der kühlschrank wirklich
optimal eingeräumt und jedes
lebensmittel jedes getränk hat seinen
platz bleibt dadurch länger haltbar und
vor allem habt ihr alles griffbereit
denn wenn der kühlschrank organisiert
ist müsst ihr wirklich nur einmal kurz
drangehen ihr wisst sofort wo alles
steht untersuchen am kühlschrank mit
offener kühlschranktür fällt wirklich
flach das gemüsefach hat die optimale
temperatur und auch das klima und so
bleiben auch empfindliche lebensmittel
wie salat obst und gemüse länger frisch
im untersten fach werden lebensmittel
gelagert die schnell verderblich sind
also wie fisch fleisch und wurst im
mittleren fach werden milchprodukte wie
quark sahne joghurt oder auch milch und
auch bei sechs bis sieben grad gelagert
in den oberen fächern dice etwas wärmer
daher die warme luft nach oben steigt
und hier werden zubereitete speisen wie
kuchen und soßen oder auch marmelade
optimal gelagert und auch bei der
kühlschranktür ist es genauso da ist
oben das war etwas kälter als unten also
werden unten nur die getränke gelagert
im mittleren fach dressings senf und
angebrochene glas konserven und im
oberen fach leicht verderbliche
lebensmittel wie zum beispiel butter
oder margarine jetzt gibt es noch ein
paar generelle tipps für den kühlschrank
und für die lebensmittel erhaltung und
zwar ist es immer besser wenn ihr
wirklich alles luftdicht verpackt das
heißt gerade angebrochene lebensmittel
wie wurst zum beispiel ich mich riecht
es immer wenn der morath sich wieder die
soto kraus genommen hat und dann einfach
in der folienverpackung wieder einstellt
und die nicht verschlossen war denn der
ganze kühlschrank richtern immer
deswegen am besten immer alles gleich
luftdicht verpacken und am besten in
durchsichtige dosen wenn dann habt ihr
auch keine besucher mehr
falls aber doch mal was offen dass im
kühlschrank stand und deckel schrank
dann wirklich nicht so gut riecht dann
könnt ihr zum beispiel gemahlenen kaffee
oder kaffeebohnen in den schildchen
stellen in den kühlschrank stellen
und dann wird wirklich der geruch
neutralisiert oder einfach kurz mit
essig wasser auswaschen und zubereitete
lebensmittel wirklich immer erst
komplett abkühlen lassen bei
raumtemperatur und dann erst rein
stellen keine warmen lebensmittel in den
kühlschrank stellen
aber braucht so viel energie
damit nichts weggeschmissen wird und
wirklich alle lebensmittel verbraucht
werden ist es ein richtig guter tipp
wirklich einen wochenplan zu machen also
überlegt euch vorher ganz gut was möchte
ich essen wann möchte ich es essen wann
möchte ich zu bereiten
macht ein wochenplan geht so einkaufen
und dann wird auch nicht weggeschmissen
ist wenn nämlich echt viel zu schade
meist hat der kühlschrank schon die
perfekte kühlschranktemperatur
eingestellt man kann ihn aber immer noch
manuell kälte einstellen das muss man
aber meist gar nicht machen und ich habe
jetzt hier mal auf den eco modus drin
das heißt der modus der wirklich am
wenigsten strom verbraucht und wenn wir
in urlaub fahren dann gibt es auch noch
den urlaubs modus dann fährt er nämlich
noch ein bisschen weiter herunter und
das ist wirklich gut macht wirklich den
kühlschrank nicht kälter als es sein
muss und wenn hinten an der rückwand
schon an gefrostet das wasser ist dann
ist er definitiv zu kalt eingestellt und
dann könnt ihr ihn wirklich ein paar
grad wärmer einstellen ein weiterer tipp
falls ihr lebensmittel aus dem
gefrierfach auftauen wollt dann macht es
nicht bei raumtemperatur oder im wasser
sondern legt am besten am tag vorher
schon in den kühlschrank denn gefrorene
ware die kündigt kühlschrank noch mal
zusätzlich
falls ihr einen ganz alten kühlschrank
da sitzt dann lege ich euch wirklich ans
herz einen neuen kühlschrank zu kaufen
er ist normalerweise mache ich nie eine
kaufempfehlung ich sagen dass ich etwas
zulegen soll
aber alte geräte haben einfach das
problem dass sie wirklich ganz ganz ganz
viel strom verbrauchen das kostet
richtig geld und wenn ihr euch einen
neuen kühlschrank zulegt dann ist müsst
ihr einfach nur beachten es gibt ja
diese bestimmten spezifikationen also
abc geräte natürlich geht ihr auf die a
geräte denn sie verbrauchen viel weniger
strom was viele nicht wissen dass ein
abschluss gerät doppelt so viel strom
verbraucht wie ein a + + + und da könnt
ihr wirklich ganz viel geld sparen denn
der alte kühlschrank oder der abschluss
kühlschrank verbraucht so viel strom
da könnt ihr euch den neuen kühlschrank
wirklich richtig
und mit einem plus + + gerät da sport
ihr wirklich richtig viel geld
wie macht man gerne das spart hier
richtig bin da spart ihr richtig viel
geld
und dann ist noch der standort des
kühlschranks ganz wichtig falls ihr also
gerade eine küche plant dann plant sie
so dass der kühlschrank nicht direkt
neben dem backofen ist wir haben es
leider nicht geschafft denn es ging bei
dieser küche einfach gar nicht anders
ich musste den backofen hier planen und
den kühlschrank hier aber wir haben hier
dazwischen der isolierung eingebaut so
dass wirklich die außentemperatur neben
dem kühlschrank viel wie möglich bleibt
es ist wirklich von vorteil wenn der
kühlschrank und backofen ganz weit weg
auseinander sind in der küche und dass
der kühlschrank einfach nicht vor einem
großen fenster steht wo einfach immer
ganz viel sonne rein strahlt denn ihr
wärmer als draußen ist und so mehr muss
der user geben auch tür da könnt ihr
wirklich bei der neuen küchenplanung
darauf achten und das dann auch
berücksichtigen oder eben dazwischen wie
bei uns die sanierung machen das waren
meine tipps zum kühlschrank und zum
energiesparen beim kühlschrank einräumen
und zur lebensmittel länger frisch
haltung
falls ihr noch tipps habt schreibt sie
gerne in die kommentare macht auf jeden
fall bei der mitmachaktion mittleres für
alle im alltag wirklich viel energie
sparen können
ich glaube die ein oder anderen tipp
habe ich schon gesehen und die waren
richtig gut da kann ich auch gerne
einmal so ein gebündeltes video darüber
machen wie kann man im alltag energie
sparen und natürlich folgen noch weitere
offene fraktions videos auch in den
anderen räumen und am besten
ich mache jetzt den kühlschrank an macht
die türe zu und am besten blick in den
kühlschrank nicht öffnen bis der
kühlschrank wieder die
kühlschranktemperatur erreicht hat das
sehen wir uns wieder beim nächsten mal